you know what Lisa
you don't speak from your own
perspective here we go what are you
talking about now you're gonna make
everybody crazy Lisa Vanderpump vs. Lisa
Rinna tonight's final reunion episode of
The Real Housewives of Beverly Hills is
explosive but it's Lisa Vanderpump
leaving the show
Tamara Matheson sat down with her for an
at-home exclusive
to find out the reunion Rabson oh thank
god hallelujah it was just such an awful
season awful it was an emotional roller
coaster in many ways it was just I felt
like I was under attack roll your eyes
all you want you're caught Lisa Rinna
seems to have really taken it to you
this season yeah she might as well have
hit me with a baseball bat rub my head
you know why own it things got so testy
a lot of people are wondering if it's
Lisa's last season is she calling it
quits I'm gonna be ambiguous on this one
because nothing's been decided yet and
for the most part I've had an amazing
time and it's given me so many
incredible platforms
Lisa's latest platform is the Vanderpump
dog foundation dedicated to improving
the lives of dogs globally it's a cause
close to her heart thank you for
inviting us into the spectacular
gorgeous home you're welcome is my zoo
really Lisa gave me a tour of her home
via Rosa which includes swans miniature
horses and eight dogs can you name them
all yeah lovely puppy cute pink dog
Snooky grumpy Avery
cheeky and Harrison can I do have a
little cuddle yeah I'm her son I almost
wore this today that would have been
really embarrassing we would have had
the same outfit